ryan cost thunder mifflin hundreds of
thousands of dollars michael ryan david
i don't care if ryan murdered his entire
family he is like a son to me
what
oh nothing
jim's been looking at me kind of a lot
all week
i would be creeped out by it but it's
nothing compared to the way michael
looks at me
this next award goes somebody really
lights up the office
somebody who i think a lot of us
cannot keep
from checking out
the hottest
in the office award goes to
ryan the 10th
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
come
from there you go there you go
what am i gonna do with the award
nothing i i don't know what i'm gonna do
that's the least of my concerns right
now
i am manuscript
in prison you are somebody's [ __ ]
oh and you you my friend would be the
belle of the ball don't drop the soap
don't drop the soap michael please
brian
[Music]
hey yeah there he is there he is he's
back and he's with a beard
he has facial hair
look at him all grown up and no place to
go hello mr sunny crockett
i'm tubbs
okay should we get started oh yeah let's
get started because uh yes because it
was a very serious business yeah and uh
exactly this is a business meeting
not that that's right that's right fire
guys there's not any fires fire guy
you weren't here for that you're for
what when he started the plan how big he
is look at you you are so
mature and old and
little man now you're like our little
man little old man boy michael everybody
um bearded man boy wow let me say
something i know i used to be a temp
here but now everything is different i'd
like your respect
i am your boss now you're gonna have to
treat me the same way you treated jan oh
wow so um that's a little kinky i don't
swing that way okay
i think ryan is a gay crush off enough
okay this is inappropriate and it stops
right now
do you understand yes
everybody come on settle down
let's get serious here um ryan has a
very special important presentation to
do which we'll be doing in the
conference room in 10 minutes perfect
sound good okay
all right
yeah ryan snapped at me but there was
this twinkle in his eye that i picked up
on which said
dude we're friends i'm doing this for
appearances i am the big boss now and i
have to seem like an ogre but you know
me
and you trust me and we like each other
and we'll always be friends
and i would never take you for granted
in a million years
and i miss you man and i love you
his words
how's my favorite branch doing
all right
ronnie was black
things were an all-time sad here but
then i got an email from ryan that he
was coming back to town and i called the
temp agency and i told them i will pay
you any amount just give me ryan howard
give him to me i want him i need him and
you gotta go tea i did did you get that
after you helped me move and you saw
mine yes
go tea
hey
hey
shaved i did
why
hey ryan look shaved off my goatee i am
goitilus we are the goatilus brothers
[Music]
wow you just dive right in
you know around age 12 i just started
going for it
oh hell
help
what what happened
it fell off the toilet
i'm caught between the toilet on the
wall
what do you need no not you
someone else get pam i think pam's gonna
want to come into the men's room get
ryan
oh he needs to lift me
and he needs to clean me up a little bit
bring a wet towel
ryan
is uh
dead no he's not i just saw him no
ladies and gentlemen may i have your
attention please
i know that a lot of you are very angry
with ryan because he is the reason we
all have to come in tomorrow however i
swear to god if any of you
hurts him in any way emotionally or
taunts him or makes fun of his height or
his half beard okay he thanks much yeah
oh ryan i need a girlfriend so bad
michael let me go let me go michael
all right
mr scott who is this other woman
ryan who you refer to here as
just as hot as jan but in a different
way not a woman just a cool
great-looking best friend aren't we
trying to determine whether michael and
jan were engaged in a romantic affair
not michael and this ryan person
excuse me all right all right well i
would definitely have sex with ryan
because he is going to own his own
business
my heart says no your heart is a
wonderful thing michael but it makes
some terrible decisions that's true yes
that's true god has gone down the wrong
path many many times
jan ryan yes why don't you give me your
contact information to start with okay
what's your cell
uh larissa halpert
what's her address 117 on bergen
street hello
hey ryan
this is michael jackson
carly from wonderland
you mean neverland
this is tito
what
college from
you talking to me
you talking to me
raging bull pacino
oh i want that footage i want it i need
it
oh i have to get back to work i have
lots of work too oh oh oh check this out
come here
there he is mr temp having lunch by the
car
let us play with him this is
oh we're playing phone tag
seven new messages first new message
hi ryan this is saddam hussein
next message hey ryan this is your
girlfriend
and i'm mad
michael are you okay
i'm just worried about my friend ryan
whoa
video ipod
oh wow jeez
somebody really got carried away with
the spirit of christmas
it was me i got carried away with the
spirit wasn't there a 20 limit on the
gift
this is 400 bucks
you don't know that yeah you left the
price tag on i did yeah what oh shoot
wow okay well who cares doesn't matter
what i spent what matters is that uh
christmas is fun right
year after year i catch a lot of flack
on this particular award because year
after year i present this award to a guy
instead of a girl hottest in the office
goes to
danny cordray
[Applause]
danny could not be here tonight how do i
feel about not winning hottest in the
office this year um i'm very relieved
how do you how do you judge science what
is his criteria even it's
it's so subjective will you marry me no
that would be hot i would pay to see
that will you marry me holly
no
only one that i was kind of worried
about
you